hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week I know you're excited this week
we're talking about cmfc control au.l
2-3.3.7 provide a system capability that
compares and synchronizes internal
system clocks with an authoritative
source to generate timestamps for audit
records
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and missed SP 800171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it with both feet but with our socks on
so hey in cmmccontrol au.l
2-3.3.7 provide a system capability that
compares and synchronizes internal
system clocks with an authoritative
source to generate timestamps for audit
records now look this control is
somewhat random it's kind of like thrown
into this thing where they're really
talking about the seam system there's
several controls in the role that talk
about you know logs and seam and
auditing and things like that and so the
big question is why is this here why do
we care about a system clock in the
middle talking about system auditing
well it turns out that knowing that your
seam alerts and time stamps are accurate
is a really big deal when it comes to
security if the timer clock is off on
your security information it may cause
you to miss important security
information alerts such as a bad login
at two o'clock in the morning right a
great example is being able to track
down
um you know failed logins or system
alerts or maybe even permission changes
that are happening in all kinds of
random times when they might not
ordinarily happen so this can definitely
be sort of hidden if your system clock
time can be altered uh or is not
synchronized with something by policy so
again let's check out what the assessors
are looking for on this one to make them
happy
so three things they're looking for
number one is determine if an internal
system clock are used to generate time
stamps for audit records uh and again if
we were to give like a sample answer
there we would say hey look system
clocks are set via Group Policy to
utilize the domain controller as the
authoritative time Source now it may not
be in domain control in your network it
could be a firewall it could be uh you
know the computers are set to directly
go to a Time server like nist dot or
time.nist.gov or something like that so
again there's a couple different answers
you could have here in this example
we're just going to use a domain
controller because it's pretty handy in
our little sample Network now the second
thing you're going to look for is
they're going to say hey determine if an
authoritative source with which to
compare and synchronize internal system
clocks is specified in other words
you're not just looking for something
internally that could be manipulated but
you're looking externally to something
that can actually be specified so in our
example we'll just okay hey it's in this
standard so we'll grab a nist Time
server because that's pretty handy right
we'll look at time.nist.gov and uh we'll
just have some group all policy in place
to say that it's specified inside the
group policy so third and final point of
assessment is determine if internal
system clocks used to generate time
stamps for audit records are compared to
and synchronized with the specified
authoritative time Source we're going to
say yes via Group Policy because group
policy in a typical sort of small to
mid-size network is going to be the easy
way to have a place to specify that
Network times Network time service so
again that's where our internal clocks
are all going to synchronize too
now uh if you're looking for help with
all this stuff and trying to figure out
what these controls mean or you just
really honestly want all this stuff done
for you the good news is here at on call
we work with defense contractors just
like you who've had this defars nist
itar and cmmc compliance stuff dropped
in their laps like a seagull on a sunny
day let me teach you how to level up and
be a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon slam more Defense
work higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
that subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance centers roll it out until the
next compliance that my friends stay
safe and secure out there and hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and I'll see you on the next
one
foreign
[Music]